welcome back subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this next segment is ready
to help you adventure through the new
year rocky stop by to find out how
burton happy new year happy new year
we're well into january but what is new
at subaru for 2022. we've got a brand
new model subaru forester wilderness i
gotta show it to you okay let's see it
come on this thing is ready for the
off-road look at this thing take on the
world in this car yes 9.2 inches of
ground clearance you've got you've got
all kinds of protections underneath the
the body there you've got a camera here
so you can see if there's rocks ahead
you got great driving lights here to
give you a good view of the up road
what's this anti-glare so you don't have
the sun beaming on that off the hood
yeah thought of everything for the
adventure it is awesome and these wheels
look ready for whatever wheels and tires
are ready for the off-road those are all
terrain yokohama geolanders and they are
designed to take you off the road the
wheels uh are really rugged and you have
a full-size spare tire to match that is
awesome and i feel like this is not just
for show there's something that's
protected right absolutely that protects
your wheel wells and the body size
because you're going to be throwing
rocks and dirt and stuff like that of
course that's because you're you're
subaru customers they love the outdoors
they love the wilderness and this car
was built for them whoa
and it looks luxurious in sight and it
is but that is not leather it is a
synthetic material that is washable it's
designed for you to get in and get out
and be dirty while you're doing it right
i love okay so what about inventory
people watching this they want this car
yeah what should they do get go online
subaru of lasvegas.com chat with one of
our associates or just drive by 6455 roy
hornway come on in here and let's tell
you how soon we can get you one you can
order the color you want with the
options you want you can customize it a
little bit yes you can
get it on the road okay let's talk about
interior because this looks very cool
yes you have all kind of controls i mean
i mean it's it is fully outfitted but i
want to focus on the fact that this
model is designed to take you off the
beaten path right it has got dual x mode
enhanced all-wheel drive that allows you
to select between mud and snow and dirt
deep mud i mean it really is it's just
an amazing uh engineering feat so we
just think it's uh it's gonna be a great
vehicle it's gonna be fun to drive and
it's gonna keep you safe absolutely
wherever you're going but now let's talk
about i know you guys give us such great
cars but also you do so much for the
community what can we expect from you
guys this year this month nevada
partnership for homeless youth we're
collecting clothes for them we want you
to bring those new and used slightly
used clothes and let's get those
together we are going to be distributing
those
at on the fourth of next month to the
youth in our valley that is awesome
thank you burton my pleasure to go for
an adventure where we going let's do uh
red rock perfect come on get in
subaru of las vegas the sponsors of this
segment i want you to visit them at 6455
roy home way call them at
702-495-2100 or visit them online at
subaru of las vegas dot com and they
have a special offer 1.9 financing for
well-qualified buyers for up to 48
months on select 2022 models
[Music]